D'abord, reportage de Charlotte
Dumoulin
- Tiens, du pain avec
des bananes, les deux - 25 %!
- La lutte contre le gaspillage
est le travail quotidien
priétaire priétaire priétaire pe
zéro-déchet à Montréal
surveillance dans
les supermarchés de Grande-
Bretagne. Comme quelques autres,
annonce qu'en septembre
des centaines de produits
sur ces étagères, dont
des fruits, n'auront plus
ANDRÉANNE LAURIN, copropriétaire
épiceries zéro déchet LOCO, MTL
- C'est sûr que d'enlever
les dates "meilleurs avant"
sur des ssaire, ça permet
vraiment d'éviter une partie
du gaspillage alimentaire.
- Le gaspillage est un problème
2 millions de tonnes d'aliments
sont gaspillés par les ménagesea
nourriture jetée aux poubelles
aurait pu être consommée.
Et plus de 1300 $ d'aliments
sont jetés par un ménage moyen
annuellement. Mais ce ne sont
laisseraient tomber le "meilleur
avant" sur les aliments pour
- Bien, il faudrait qu'il y ait
des garantis que c'est vraiment
- Moi ça me dérange pas et
j'ai un peu l'habitude de
flairer les escomptes pour
les trucs qui sont près de
- À mon avis, ça ferait pas
de diffé moi.
- Pour certains, l'initiative
est écologique. Pour d'autreue.
JACQUES NANTEL, professeur,
Département marketing, HEC, Mtl
- Si ces détaillants-là
le font,'évidemment, la Grande-
Bretagne comme le Canada passe
par une forte inflation.
Et en ce moment, tout le monde
notamment les coûts d'opération,
mais églament les coûts de
gaspillage chez le consommateur.
- Les supermarchers sont
ouverts à de nouvelles règles
sur l'étiquettage des aliments,e
l'Association des détaillants
en alimentation du Québec.
Asso. détaillants alimentation
- Peu importe ce qui va êtr
écrit sur le paquet, c'est
important de pouvoir donner
au consommateur.
b
du gouvernement canadien :
En retirant cette indication de
certainsque Waitrose pense
éviter le gaspillage
de 7 millions de paniers
de nourriture.
Radio-Canada, Mon